Madame undersecretary thank you for the
interview and welcome on the program
secretary pump air in December said that
the US will withdraw from the INF treaty
unless Russia complies within 60 days
the deadline is approaching it is set
for the 2nd of February what are the
codes that they use will eventually
withdraw from the INF treaty yeah well
first of all Thank You Gianna for making
the time this is an incredibly important
topic and treaty and with the German
counterparts a Russian audience and the
European partners such no important
parts I think so the opportunity first
and foremost be able to talk about it
you may know that we did meet with our
russian my russian counterpart the
deputy foreign minister last week in
Geneva to discuss this and unfortunately
made no new ground
we continued to raise the points and a
reminder reminded viewers that this has
gone over two administrations over five
years so the Obama administration and
now the Trump administration and Russia
still continues to violate the treaty so
we raised specific questions they have
heard many of them before and
unfortunately the Russian response so
they continue to violate the treaty so
you think that the decision will be on
the US part to withdraw from the treaty
well we've been clear like as you
mentioned the secretary spoke clearly in
December that Russia was in a material
breach and know we would invoke that it
had 60 days as you mentioned on February
2nd and if Russia isn't in compliance by
February 2nd that our attempt is to
suspend our obligations under the treaty
we've mentioned it with partners and
allies we've got great support I was
just in NATO last week briefed the knack
great support from the secretary-general
and our NATO partners yeah the the
treaty is very clear and our obligations
are very clear and unfortunately Russia
continues to violate it but February 2nd
if they're not compliant will suspend
our obligations what's the difference
you don't mention withdrawal you mention
suspension and I read the end of treaty
and
doesn't provide for suspension what's
been different
no it's it does the suspension again we
had said we will suspend it and then a
six-month clock runs if you will during
that time Russia still can get back into
compliance but it frees our obligations
under the treaty so we suspends our
obligations with the intent to withdraw
if they don't get back in compliance but
we have I'd admire 3t for the entire
time and by suspending our obligations
that we'll be able to do the research
and development of similar systems that
Russia now has fully fielded in in the
field so Russia in this case would have
another six months to be in compliance
they do what are these exactly missile
in question of that Russia allegedly
possesses that are not compliant with
the treaty could you could you name this
right so the SSC aid is that is then is
the NATO nomenclature that I'm 79 in the
Russian to know which system it is we've
continued to meet with them and show
them intelligence and information on why
this system is not in compliance we've
continued to show them the test dates
locations of when they conducted the
tests that our intelligence community
and our partners we've shared that
information as well and they continue to
deny that the test results were the same
we've shared this information we worked
very hard with our intelligence
community to get the intelligence what
they call downgraded so we can share it
with our NATO partners and share it with
other allies and you've seen the results
in response all of our NATO partners and
allies continue to call out Russia said
they've seen the information they
support our efforts to uphold the
obligations of the treaty but Russia
also claims that the u.s. is not
compliant with the treaty and the
example they are always mentioned is
that the United States deploys an
anti-missile system in Romania and there
is a special missile launcher that is
not compliant are these claims true
they're not true and Russia's the only
country that continues to raise these
again other parties to the treaty our
NATO partner and allies continued to say
America the United
States's in compliance with the INF
treaty Russia continues to raise the
aegis ashore and among other things we
continue to provide them facts and
information why these systems our treaty
compliant again they're the holy nation
that calls us out our NATO partners and
allies have been on board and we've gone
back and continued again fact-based
evidence-based intelligence based and
provide this with the Russians on why
that system
Russians verify that these missile
launches are compliant with the treaty
or they are not allowed to get into this
anti-missile system base right well as
part of the treaty you don't get to just
randomly check other nations systems
that's that would isn't part and purview
of the treaty but we have provided them
with the intelligence again in fact
space data as of our partners and they
continued with their rhetoric its
rhetoric and propaganda it's it's
laughable quite honestly they continue
to grope and for and grasp for for other
reasons to try to kind of obfuscate and
mask the their violations so the world
sees it for what it is and the violation
of the treaty and we continue to hold
them accountable you always refer to
verifiable results so they INF treaty
provides for special verification
Commission does it still exist it does
yeah we've continued to abide by that
we've continued to meet our obligations
with the treaty
we've called meetings and we've met our
technical experts continue to meet as as
scheduled nez requested again we've
continued to abide by the treaty it's
not that the door is closed the doors
been open but just Russia's continues to
violate continues not to field as as I
tell folks this isn't a research and
development system this isn't in a lab
this isn't a testing ground
these are fielded battalions these are
in the field today with soldiers manned
and equipped to use these systems that
can impact Europe and our partners so I
would like just to mention that the INF
treaty is a bilateral agreement signed
when the Soviet Union still existed and
now other countries which are not
parties to this treaty including for
example China these countries possess a
lot of these missiles and missile
launches that are prohibited by the
treaty apart from other things do you
think that the u.s. possible withdrawal
from the INF treaty can be in national
and American national interests because
of the change in landscape and of a
purin of like big country's powerful
place in global arms race you raise a
great point and the fact that the United
States continues to abide by our
obligations as the undersecretary for
arms control and international security
and all of our arms control experts will
tell you you know the foundation of a
successful arms control regime is
abiding by the treaty that you sign up
holding your obligations as a
responsible nation-state the United
States continues to abide by our
responsibilities we continue to abide by
the piece of paper that we signed as do
the other parties other than Russia it
undermines all of our arms control areas
and under undermines our arms control
regimes so in the day it's about the
defense for the American people and with
our partnership with our partners and
allies so if if brusha isn't get them in
compliance in February second we have
abided by it we haven't done the
research envelop we both can we will do
that and but they mean another thing so
I am referring to mr. Bolton's interview
that he gave to commerce and it's the
Russian national newspaper and he
mentioned and he quoted present from
that for this treaty and not to be
outdated to preconditions should be met
one is a compliance of Russia and
another is the decision of China to
eliminate non-compliant missiles and
missile launches although China is not a
part of the treaty
yeah the INF treaty and our discussions
today with INF treaty is with Russia it
is with the Russian government and their
leadership and they know what they need
to do to get back into compliance we've
been very clear our partners have been
very clear the failure of the INF treaty
at this juncture is all about Russia
so you don't think that it the station
has changed a lot in the world and the
US withdrawal might be beneficial for
the country to ensure its security
because of growing our arms race and
growing threats coming from other
countries like China absolutely the
global environment has changed the world
as when President Reagan signed the
document in the world today is in a very
different place as you've mentioned
China has fielded systems that if they
were party to the treaty would violate
the treaty as have other nations started
with their research and development but
the INF treaty is about Russia I Nephi
was about Union Russia back into
compliance but absolutely the world
today is very different for when this
treaty was designed like again to
underscore that the importance of arm
control so China is not in question this
is about Russia
that's about Russia so as you might know
President Putin and his national address
said that Russia had developed new types
of arms and he also mentioned that
Russia actually had no other choice
because the United States of America
withdrew from their anti-ballistic
missile treaty back in 2012 2012 sorry
these are police concerns justified
they're not there's not a valid
discussion again it's rhetoric it's
propaganda it's not facts base we
continue to see that and hear that time
and time again we heard it and saw it
yesterday with the mock-up demonstration
of the system that most people didn't
attend and and quite candidly those that
did attend weren't able to ask questions
it was a static as laughable so as
Russians say that if the transparency
manager I think most most professionals
to tell you is quite laughable a static
display isn't gonna prove that the
missiles range so again its rhetoric its
propaganda we use fact-based decision
making that's what you're saying that
that's laughable that means that these
new arms that couldn't presented in
front of the in his national address not
to the people but to the up to the
Parliament so these actually are arms do
not exist no what it see is laughable is
the static demonstration yesterday
the static display of the system doesn't
prove what the system can and cannot do
again they continue we have seen we've
seen it with this treaty what their
obligations are versus what they're
doing in two different places so we are
concerned with the development of Russia
systems and we're going to again protect
the United States citizens a work and
collaboration with partners and allies
to make sure we protect ourselves and if
that means new systems and research and
development we'll cross that bridge
identity it's about the national
security interests of protecting
Americans and working with our partners
and we've seen the importance of that as
the violations with INF treaty but do
you find these arms that are represented
would you regard them as a potential
threat to the American security I can
tell you today with multiple fielded
battalions of an INF violating missile
system that is a threat to our European
partners and allies and it's a threat to
Americans the Russians have the
capability of a system that's in
violation of a treating we have an
obligation protect our interests so
there are reports from the INF treaty
there are other treaties that ensure
global security and among one of them is
the so-called New START treaty and it's
gonna it's gonna expire in two thousand
two thousand twenty one twenty one do
you think that these treaty will be
expanded or not what I can tell you is
the New START treaty we are in
compliance as is Russia they were
meeting their obligations under New
START we met our central limits in
February of last year as did the
Russians they continue to do inspections
underneath chart we continue to do
inspections underneath start I would say
we have two more years as much in 2021
is when it expires we're not at the
table today to discuss New START worth
table today to discuss INF but right now
both both countries are meeting their
obligations on the new start so there is
another important issue it's addressed
to non-proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction do you think that Russia
actually breaks this the treaties
associated with that with this
proliferation the does Russia actually
transfer these weapons of mass
destruction to internationally
sanctioned countries like Iran or like
Syria I can tell you that preventing the
proliferation of those technologies is
incredibly important for our global
security I'll be meeting next week in
Beijing the p5 I'll be meeting with my
Chinese counterpart I'll be meeting with
the Deputy Foreign Minister Sergei
Ryabkov I'll be meeting with again the
p5 with the Brits and the French to
continue to emphasize and talk about the
importance of this non-proliferation how
we work together as a p5 I hope and
trust that Russia will come to the table
with some some tangibles that we can
discuss because it is of critical
importance but for now they have any
proof that Russia probably transferred
or still transferring some weapons some
types of weapons of mass destruction to
sanctioned countries and I'm most
interested in in Syria I wouldn't want
to talk about intelligence information
obviously in the open Network but I can
tell you to underscore the importance of
preventing the proliferation of these
technologies to rogue nations to
non-state actors and that's why we're
important discussions coming up next
week in the p51 controversial thing
about Syria is that back in 2014 then
President Barack Obama claimed that all
our most dangerous weapons of mass
destruction chemical weapons have been
destroyed nevertheless there were
attacks after this after 2014
how could you explain this well where
did they get this chemical weapons from
well again new coach talks about support
to rogue actors and rogue nations the
Assad regime Falls clearly in that area
and I would tell you this some great
grounds being made but probably note
with the OPCW the attribution mechanism
on the use clearly striking back both in
Syria and with the Novacek the Russian
use of Novacek agents in the UK so again
responsible actors and nation-states
have spoken we cannot tolerate this
behavior we will not tolerate these
actions there needs to be repercussions
with this and there needs to be an
attribution mechanism and we're working
together with partners and allies and
made great grounds or
two and a half in that area but I'm
interested with the organization for the
prohibition of chemical weapons was
wrong with the analysis that they gave
back in 2014 or something else happened
what do you think
you know I I've done 28 years in uniform
as an intelligence officer and fully in
an intelligence picture it's like
putting a puzzle together sometimes you
have some of the pieces but not all and
it takes time to get those pieces and
through the great work with partners and
allies sharing information working with
different agencies and we put that
information together and now being able
to do the attribution mechanism whether
it's the Russians in Salisbury or the
actions in Syria so we continue to work
hand in glove with our partners and
together we'll continue to so you're not
afraid to reveal all the results of this
of this investigation into this chemical
attacks yeah I think the OPC that he's
been very clear on the attribution
mechanism and I would anticipate will
continue to develop that picture and
they've been clear to call out Russia on
the violations that they have they can
look at the global security situation
right now Russia is on top of the agenda
as a disruptive country but do you think
that only Russia is a disruptive country
in the context of global security you
know the global environment is extremely
challenging there's you know actions
from state actors non-state actors but
we continue to have a dialogue with
Russia the president has said it the
secretary have said it we're calling
them out where they're in violation but
they're the other areas that we're
working together and so the dialogue
needs to occur but we call people out
when they violate their their
responsibilities and with the INF treaty
clear violation from Russia I mean so
the you see right now but probably us I
will withdraw from the INF treaty it
withdrew from this anti-ballistic
missile treaty back in 2002 we are not
sure about New START do you think that
the picture has changed and this
architecture that used to be very
efficient I don't know a decade or two
decades ago is not more is now not
viable
I would say you have to assess the
threat environment as you stand today
and assess where these are we've
fulfilled our obligations under these
treaties we will continue to discuss if
they are still relevant but until then
we abide by our obligations we've done
so with the INF will continue to do so
but again it the world is in a different
place and when these various treaties
were signed will fulfill our obligations
as long as we're in that treaty they
expect a renewed arms race with rational
problem with other countries take into
account that Russia is developing new
arms systems it's gonna be a new arms
race or not well as I tell folks they
talk about the challenges is there gonna
be an arms race and I remind them that
Russia has fielded battalions of these
systems so right now there's a race the
Russians are clearly violating and in
started the so-called race will continue
to abide by the treaty will conduct
research and development when and if
we're allowed to do so after the second
will always develop systems that help
protect our global interests for the
United States and working with our
partners and allies and this is a great
example of that if you look at the
situation right now that has
substantially changed and the situation
that was in the times of Cold War what
are the differences and similarities
between these two situations I could
probably do a couple more news shows
with you to describe the threat
environment I mean obviously technology
has changed partnerships have changed
the threat environment from radical
Islamic threat to state actors have
changed but fortunately we've got a
great team here and continue to assess
that we continue to work with our
partners DoD across the interagency and
partners and allies whether it be in the
Middle East Europe or globally around
the world to best protect those
interests I think that the situation the
a security situation right now is better
that the environment is more secure than
it was back in their times of the
I don't think you really can compare
contrast the worlds in two very
different places than we were in the
1980s and where we are today
again I've served a nation for over 30
years and in various war zones in
conflict areas and again there there are
threats there and we will continue to
mitigate those threats both with our
systems our people and work with our
partners and allies to best protect the
interests the secretary Thompson thank
you very much for the interview and best
of luck for you thanks so much for the
opportunity appreciate it thank you
you